[Música]
en primera plana
braulio moro
[Música]
bienvenidos a en primera plana una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español un debate agita el mundo de
los economistas la reaparición de la
inflación un espectro que da miedo a no
pocos analistas ya responsables de las
instituciones internacionales que es la
inflación cómo afecta el bolsillo de
ustedes se lo explicamos aquí en unos
instantes en primera plana
[Música]
para comprender qué tan importante es
este tema que tan justificado es este
temor cómo puede afectarles a ustedes
qué tan buena o mala es la inflación
saludamos ya a nuestros invitados
álvaro zúñiga doctor ante en la parís
school of economics además es usted
miembro afiliado al laboratorio mundial
de las desigualdades bienvenido así es
muchas gracias encantado de estar aquí
karen woo es periodista independiente
especializada en el sector turismo karen
bienvenida también la primera plana
muchas gracias pero con clase y
finalmente a distancia tenemos a
jean-pierre 2 la un economista de la
universidad parís es tomar la vallée
especializado en temas de economía verde
buenos días
jean-pierre buenos días gracias por la
invitación a auto ahora vamos a ver qué
dicen algunas de las portadas de los
diarios internacionales sobre este
espinoso tema abrimos con el británico
financial times quien con grandes letras
escribe el ascenso de la inflación de
estadounidense pone en duda la visión de
la reserva federal sobre los precios
temporalmente elevados al otro lado del
atlántico el 'new york post' se agita
también y titula con grandes letras
la increíble contracción del dólar la
inflación sube a 54 % la peor en 13 años
finalmente la revista española inversión
presenta a la directora del banco
central europeo- christine lagard
maniatada acompañada del título de
inflación ya nos vuelve locos y karen
bujes asistimos realmente a un rebrote
permanente de la inflación que pueda
justificar esta expresión de la revista
inversión de que nos pone locos
bueno parece que la tendencia con el
cómic ha hecho que haya un desequilibrio
entre la oferta y la demanda no se
estaba previniendo nos estaba diciendo
no previniendo que hubieran
en el momento de que del parón con el
cob y tuviera un reajuste después de esa
demanda porque se aumentó el consumo y
no estaba no estaba preparado entonces
en este desequilibrio la inflación que
no deja de ser que los precios suben
tanto para escribir servicios como
productos se haya vuelto
muy inestable y entonces es christine
lagarde sí que ha optado por este
equilibrio no por ese 2% de esa tasa de
inflación efectivamente y sí que va a
tratar de haber otra reunión que no pase
20 años para que vuelva a ocurrir
entonces no se sabe hay una
incertidumbre grande no se sabe si va a
ser algo permanente sino porque al final
depende también mucho de el tema de la
variante del está con la con el cob y la
evolución que va a haber también un
respecto en todos los países porque sólo
el 1% de estos países que es sordo mi
compañero álvaro va a hablar de ello
entiendo que están en desigualdad no con
bajos o bajos medios ingresos sólo el 1%
está vacunado entonces esto al final no
afecta a nivel global y que los países
ricos cuando el g7 decidieron distribuir
dosis de vacunación al final no
distribuyan su 11 mil millones de dosis
sino sólo en mil millones vamos a ver
los efectos precisamente desafiantes de
la situación de la economía
internacional y concretamente de la
inflación
solicitarán pierdes lo que recuerdo nos
acompaña a la distancia
jean-pierre que ha provocado la
inflación que vemos brotar a izquierdas
y a derechas pero en la actualidad ha
habido diversos factores viendo una
combinación de estos factores que han
influido el aumento de la inflación
basado en grandes estímulos fiscales
monetarios impulsado por los bancos
centrales cada país con fines de
mantener el consumo y evitar justamente
que se produzca este colapso económico
un estímulo adicional es la subida de
los precios
lo que constituye el efecto producto la
vacunación contra incluir que puede ser
un factor cae para frenar el cursar una
cierta actividad económica en este
sentido la gran calidad que vive los
mercados financieros durante el 20
cuando estalló la crisis financiera el
repunte inflacionario no sólo se está
viendo en europa sino que también en
américa latina a medida que avanza la
vacunación y se reactiva el consumo
según el banco interamericano de
desarrollo del bid la mayoría de los
precios de los bienes básicos han
aumentado desde el 2021 estoy
influenciado por las importaciones de
china las compras que eran de eeuu y la
recuperación económica en europa y por
cierto los precios de ciertos como dije
o producto de américa latina como la
soya el azúcar el café el hierro el
cobre y por cierto muy importante el
petróleo dentro de las materias primas
gracias jean-pierre álvaro tenemos ya
algunos elementos aportados por karen
por jean-pierre ahora bien los temores
ligados a esta ola de inflación por lo
que comenta karen parecían contenerse a
partir de este rebrote de inflación que
tanto puede afectar efectivamente este
posible rebrote a nivel internacional
la recuperación económica y como
consecuencia en la inflación
claro
parte del problema en este momento es
que no sabemos qué tan que tan
significativa va a ser esa recuperación
económica precisamente porque no sabemos
cuáles son los efectos de las nuevas
variantes en particular la variante
delta y no sabemos cómo va a progresar
el proceso de vacunación en los
diferentes mercados eso genera
incertidumbre pero hoy que estamos
hablando de inflación esa incertidumbre
más bien nos hace temer un poco menos a
la inflación es cierto que hay inflación
en el mundo en este momento ahora no es
la misma en todos los países la mayoría
de titulares se refieren a los estados
unidos la unión europea presenta
muchísimo menos inflación e inclusive la
de eeuu muchos argumentarán que no es
preocupante la de la unión europea es
más baja la de japón es probablemente
aún más baja y la del mundo de países en
desarrollo es es es en este momento no
es preocupante excepto algunos países
que son la excepción entonces si hay una
inflación que se sale un poco de la
norma de los últimos años pero no
sabemos si va a ser permanente no
sabemos si tenemos que preocuparnos
uno de los atenuantes para preocuparse
es precisamente que no sabemos qué tan
fuerte va a ser la recuperación
económica' muy bien recordemos que hay
muchas variables que explican
precisamente el surgimiento la explosión
que puede haber en un momento dado de
una ola inflacionaria normalmente se
entiende recordemos como inflación un
aumento de los precios de los bienes sea
de los servicios por una ausencia de la
oferta que nos sigue la demanda es un
poco técnico esto pero esperemos que lo
comprendan ustedes y también hay otra
razón que puede explicar un incremento
de la inflación es cuando uno se pone a
echar a andar la máquina de fabricar
billetes a este propósito precisamente
hemos visto que en los últimos meses
tanto en eeuu como en la unión europea
han sido ha lanzado planes
multimillonarios de rescate para
incentivar la economía
karen en este sentido esos planes pueden
ser un motivo que esté incentivando
notablemente en el caso de eeuu el
rebrote de la inflación por supuesto al
final la inflación recibe en la
situación económica que nos encontramos
no nos deja ser una herramienta también
de macroeconomía
y una forma también de equilibrar tanto
el fet como el banco central europeo
de equilibrar todo todo lo que ha pasado
desde ese desequilibrio no por esta
oferta y esta demanda durante la
temporada de del cob y entonces xxi está
directamente relacionado no porque hay
otras causas también que implica esta
inflación no que es la expectativas no
que haya a nivel a nivel económico así
como también la parte de que haya haya
una previsión de demanda desigualdad en
desigualdad entonces pero pero esto la
inflación hay que verla como el enemigo
puesto que como ha dicho mi compañero en
europa no está del todo a la elevada y
se puede controlar y luego por otro lado
hay ciertas cosas que la inflación
provoca que sólo pueden ser positivas
como pueden ser activar la economía al
final cuando cuando los precios se
elevan en lo que es el ahorro disminuye
porque el poder
del valor del dinero también disminuye y
sin ti va también más a las inversiones
también por otro lado entonces una serie
de factores positivos que es por lo que
hacen que tanto la fed como como el
banco central europeo decida mover estos
valores y también cambiar el tipo de
interés para poder jugar un poco con
esta parte incentiva esa economía en que
resurja y aprovechar este es esa
coyuntura económica que estamos viviendo
entonces parte parte de las cosas
positivas que tiene esa inflación es eso
incentivar la economía es que hayan más
inversiones y sí que se pierde poder
adquisitivo que esto quizás lo que les
interesa sobre todo a los que nos están
viendo pero normalmente se entiende a
equilibrar con el aumento de los
salarios eso lo veremos en un instante
más precisamente álvaro comentaba hace
unos instantes
la presidenta de la banca central
europea christine lagarde ha tenido una
reunión ayer jueves han anunciado un
cambio radical de la estrategia seguida
por el banco central europeo en los
últimos 20 años anteriormente se fijaba
con un límite el 2% de inflación anual y
lo que han decidido ahora lo ha dicho
claramente es ya no sólo es que tiene
que ser inferior al 2% sino dice ya
podrá ser de manera transitoria superior
al 2% anualizado es decir el banco
central acepta finalmente dejar este
papel de guardián del templo de la
ortodoxia inflacionaria monetaria pienso
que tal vez es un poco es un poco
exagerado decir que es el que va a dejar
la ortodoxia creo que mantiene el
promedio de dos solo que acepta irse
para arriba antes sólo aceptaba estar
por debajo de dos así es y creo que la
proyección para finales de año es un 2.6
que sigue siendo muy baja
y no no no pareciera que apunte a una
alta tendencia inflacionaria lo otro que
es importante mencionar es que cuando se
habla de inflación no sólo importa la de
un año específico sino importa los lados
los años anteriores de los años
posteriores y lo que se busca es tener
una tendencia a un promedio ponderado de
estos varios años que no se aleje mucho
de dos entonces aunque la de este año
sea mayor a dos oa lo que sea que sea la
meta del banco central si la del año
anterior fue menor porque fue menor y la
de los años posteriores va a ser menor
al final digamos ese aumento de hoy
compensa un poco a la pérdida de ayer y
de mañana muy bien
jean-pierre recuerdo que usted de esta
distancia la inflación puede poner en
peligro la frágil y desigualdad
reactivación económica
en américa latina el exceso y el acceso
desigual a las vacunas y la aparición de
nuevas variantes del virus aumenta la
incertidumbre sobre la evolución de la
pandemia y la consiguiente recuperación
de esta economía un informe de la cepal
en santiago el chile de julio menciona
que se ha propiciado la reactivación en
base un mayor crecimiento de eeuu y
china también el aumento de los precios
de las materias primas en conjunto con
la apertura económica y la
flexibilización del cáncer en todos mis
hijos que antiguamente era mucho más
duro durante el 2020 es los países de
nuestra nación anuncia medidas fiscales
sin precedentes estos de nuevo los
efectos negativos de la pandemia pero
aumentó la desigualdad y la pobreza en
chicos factores en este sentido los
medios fiscales se enfocaron justamente
en fortalecer el sistema de salud
pública apoyar las familias mediante
transferencias monetarias ya proteger la
estructura productiva de los países a
través de tus justamente de asegurar la
liquidez de la economía ante la
persistencia de esta pandemia en los
países de latinoamérica no hicieron
entre julio en enero y julio ver donde
el 2021 nuevo paquete fiscal en
ejercicio que van directamente a la
ayuda de la economía
ahora no solamente estos ajustes en
política monetaria y fiscal influirán en
la reactivación por ciento sino que
también procesos políticos como la nueva
institución en chile en la asunción de
nuevo gobierno en posibles problemas
políticos y están viviendo en argentina
y colombia que generan mucha
incertidumbre y producirán una cierta
desaceleración que pueden estar
justamente en este crecimiento durante
el año 2022
gracias yampier vamos a hacer una breve
pausa en unos instantes más estamos de
vuelta aquí en primera plana
[Música]
bienvenidos a las noticias
fernando me confiaría un abismo
jugándose en un examen
no
[Música]
21 omar gasca fifa
según wagner casi 99 millones de ustedes
nos siguen cada semana en france 24
antiguas en su cronistas cuyo compromiso
es más muchas gracias
su gran dirigente contador beijing
primer se deformó acá
[Música]
liberté égalité actual y t
estamos de vuelta aquí en primera plana
en compañía de nuestros invitados
salvaron su nigga doctor antes de la
parís school of economics miembro
afiliado al laboratorio internacional de
las desigualdades declaren burgués
periodista independiente especializada
en temas de turismo y a distancia jean
pierre nuncio economista de la
universidad parís smart la vallée
especializado en economía verde me
gustaría tratar brevemente en esta
segunda parte algunos elementos que
tienen que ver con la evolución de los
precios de las materias primas las
repercusiones en los países menos
desarrollados y eventualmente si tiempo
nos queda ver un poco las perspectivas
de la inflación de aquí a fin de año
incluso al 2022
álvaro los precios de las materias
primas han subido recientemente en
algunos países que países que
generalmente son países en vías de
desarrollo le doy algunos ejemplos las
materias primas plásticas que sirven
para el envasado de productos lácteos
han subido el 50 por ciento en un año el
material para fabricar cartón 20 por
ciento el precio de la tonelada de maíz
40 desde el 2020 el trigo 25% el cobre
superó los 10 mil dólares por tonelada
en mayo pasado un récord histórico
qué tan bueno o malo es esto para la
economía de las economías precisamente
menos desarrolladas claro claro es una
muy buena pregunta
antes de responder qué tan buena un malo
ahí es importante tal vez tomar unos
segundos para explicar por qué han
subido una de las razones por las que ha
subido es porque el año pasado bajaron
entonces hay un efecto de rebote del
rebote de los precios que si lo hacemos
en una escala interanual pues vemos que
han subido las materias primas pero es
porque el año pasado en medio de la
pandemia en este mismo momento del
verano del hemisferio norte los precios
estaban muy bajos y ahora la lectura nos
da que está muy alto eso es una de las
razones no es la única hay un problema
más estructural que venía desde antes de
la pandemia que también es muy
interesante ahora dicho eso cómo afecta
esto de los países en desarrollo y los
países sobre todo productores de
materias primas pues en principio es una
cosa buena es una buena cosa que el
cobre en chile se pague mejor son
mayores ingresos en los países son
mayores ingresos pero y eso se
probablemente se traduciría en cifras
macroeconómicas
en una mejora de la producción de esas
economías en un momento específico pero
hay que trascender un poco esta visión y
hay que preguntarse qué tanto de esta
mejora en la producción total se refleja
en una disminución de la pobreza y en
una disminución de la desigualdad y aquí
es donde yo sería un poco más escéptico
de pensar que un aumento del precio de
una materia prima se va a traducir
innecesariamente en menor pobreza y
menor desigualdad en países que han
sufrido muchísimo porque hablando de
inflación que es el tema que nos ocupa
hoy quizá más importante en este momento
que la inflación para las economías en
desarrollo ha sido la pérdida de empleo
y la destrucción digamos de
microempresas que eran los medios de
subsistencia de una parte importante de
esa población entonces si los mayores
precios de las materias primas no se
traduce en políticas que redistribuyan o
incentiven esta parte de la economía en
muchos casos informal y yo no veo que
vaya necesariamente a disminuir la
desigualdad gracias al valor vamos de
nuevo con young & founds
cuál es la opinión a propósito
precisamente lo que está pasando con
esta situación en américa latina
jean-pierre d'uixó los bancos sociales
tienden a incrementar la tasa de interés
en los préstamos al consumo como la
tarjeta de créditos las hipotecas esto
efe la demanda de productos el lado
negativo del final además de producto el
que se frena en las industrias lo cual
puede llevar a un estancamiento
económico y de tener justamente esta
ganancia reactivación que está
comentando como ejemplo dentro los
bancos centrales de brasil chile también
de colombia y de méxico están subiendo
las aceiteras y las seguirán
probablemente subiendo durante 2022 otra
manera de limitar este efecto sería
justamente limitar la necesidad de
financiamiento y reducir el déficit
fiscal esto es muy difícil sabiendo la
necesidad de aumentar el gasto fiscal en
salud y en nuestros áreas de la columna
de la región
otra sería varían los impuestos lo que
ellos ya solamente por las empresas y
sería ir en contra también de la
reactivación una vida de adicional sería
realizar una reforma fiscal que implicó
una disminución del tamaño del estado y
de sus gastos administrativos esto se
está realizando como todos sabemos mente
ecuador con alguna algunos temas de
protestas al respecto en referencia a la
recuperación vértigo usted menciona la
realidad es que la recuperación
económica global dista mucho de ser una
recuperación verde y sólo el 18 por
ciento de los minutos comprometidos en
la recuperación son verdes y favorecen
al cambio climático según informaciones
de la 1 dicho de esto ya mi modo de ver
las finanzas sostenibles sobre el camino
hacia la recuperación económica del
futuro a través de los bonos verdes
emitidos como por ejemplo en colombia
que lo he hecho
hace un tiempo para financiar proyectos
de energías limpias también lo
relacionado a la reducción de las
emisiones y también el trabajo que se ha
empezado a realizar en varios países la
región sobre hojas de ruta de economía
circular
gracias jean pierre pasa y tiene una
pista usted es el desarrollo de la
economía verde para favorecer
precisamente la reactivación de las
economías y eventualmente contener los
efectos de la inflación pero antes que
eso yo quisiera hacer una pregunta a
álvaro recordando que eres especialista
en temas también de desigualdad
evidentemente si a alguien afecta el
problema de la inflación a esa las
gentes con menores niveles de ingresos
en el contexto de américa la tiene en
particular este rebrote que se ve en
algunos países de la inflación qué
consecuencias tiene sabiendo como los
señalaba que al mismo tiempo hay un
aumento de los precios de las materias
primas claro es la teoría es muy clara
la inflación la pagan mal los pobres y
es una es un impuesto muy regresivo en
ese sentido en que afecta más la canasta
de bienes y servicios que consumen los
pobres de hecho hay un estudio reciente
que se hizo para eeuu donde en realidad
en la canasta adaptada al cobit es aún
más la inflación medida por la canasta
adaptada al cob y es aún mayor que la
que utilizamos exacto
normalmente con la canasta no adaptada
al precio la canasta porque el consumo
se ha se ha hecho hacia el lado de los
alimentos y ciertos servicios que
consumimos en las casas en lugar de
otros servicios que ya no consumimos y
entonces se estima que la inflación es
en realidad mayor de la que se había
estimado el año pasado pero dicho dicho
eso es ese es muy preocupante lo que lo
que puede tener es el efecto de esta
inflación en américa latina pero insisto
que lo que es aún más preocupante de la
pérdida de medios de subsistencia en
pérdida de trabajo pérdida de un mercado
informal que durante meses no funcionó
qué tiene que ver con las restricciones
sanitarias que no nos permitían salir
todo todo esto ha sido muchísimo más
traumático para las personas que
probablemente unos puntos más de
inflación que lo que estamos viendo en
este momento ahora la inflación hay que
tenerle mucho cuidado y los bancos
centrales que están reaccionando como
méxico como brasil pero también como
sudáfrica o sudáfrica o como rusia que
han subido tasas de interés lo hacen con
justa razón la inflación hay que temerle
porque ella
vemos los efectos muy negativos que
tiene sobre precisamente los grupos de
menor ingreso pero el riesgo de sobre
reaccionar es enfriar precisamente la
economía como decíamos hace un rato y
que eso genere en lugar de inflación una
deflación o un estancamiento de la
economía que sería aún más peligroso que
un escenario de unos 2 o 3 puntos
porcentuales mayor de inflación gracias
alvaro en todo caso ya lo tienen ustedes
a la inflación hay que vigilarla como la
leche en la lumbre karen una pregunta de
seamos eres especialistas en temas de
turismo hemos visto el tema de las
desigualdades pero sin duda alguna la
inflación como la pandemia han afectado
radicalmente sustancialmente al turismo
al turismo al afecta a todo decir cuando
una percepción de inseguridad en un país
también afecta cuando hay una percepción
de que en este caso los precios están
más elevados también afectan a las
intenciones de viajar
y todo lo que ha pasado con la pandemia
de hecho ha sido el detonante de ese
desplome que se produjo en marzo del
turismo sobre todo internacional porque
sí que el turismo interno no sí que se
ha potenciado un poco más y entonces
aquí nos encontramos con la variación
mundial del turismo que ha sido rotundo
rotunda y lo que nos dice es que hay que
apostar por tecnología digital que lo
hemos ido viendo a lo largo de este año
hay que apostar por aumentar la
confianza como como podemos aumentar la
confianza de los ciudadanos a viajar
pues que los países tengan hasta
adaptados todas las medidas
correctamente que las vacunaciones se
amplíen para que esté seguro y que haya
una comunicación sobre todo muy abierta
entre el sector turismo turístico y los
ciudadanos respecto a cómo viajar qué
medidas hay y aquí también parte de ese
empuje lo tienen los gobiernos de
facilitar y de dar esa sensación de
confianza entonces la tendencia ahora el
turismo internacional
y seguirá estando desplomado por lo
menos parece que hasta el año que viene
no va a remontar sí que es cierto que
por ejemplo el turismo interno sí que se
está potenciando más países que se
encuentran en toda la unión europea han
podido beneficiarse de ello sobre todo
con este pase sanitario digital del cob
it que sobre todo países como francia
ahora mismo están haciendo de que de que
para poder libre movimiento no sobre
todo y favorecer ese turismo interno
pues puede enseñar un test de negativo
de pcr o bien la vacuna que tengan las
dos dosis el circo de ciclo completo y
bueno todo esto favorece a que el
turismo interno por lo menos sí que se
está revitalizando pero la caída del
turismo internacional ha sido en 183 por
ciento respecto al año anterior respecto
a 2019 disculpe que es un poco como
estaba en esa situación entonces todavía
queda trabajo que hacer y que éste en
lugar de pagar también ha sido ha sido
muy contundente respecto a este tema que
hay que potenciar lo que es
vacunación para tener más libertad y
reactivar el turismo pero todo caso por
lo que me explicas en todo momento en
todo caso por ahora la inflación no
parece ha de ser un factor que afecte al
turismo es un puerto el contexto de la
pandemia
hay pocos aumentos de precios en general
en el turismo entiendo es más el
contexto de la pared de la pandemia a
nivel general por qué intenciones de
viajar sí que lo hay pero hay que
aumentar la confianza pero la inflación
a nivel si se percibe es aumento de
precios sí que puede quitar la intención
de viajar no reducirla sin embargo nos
encontramos en un momento ahora donde se
preocupan más por esa facilidad de
viajar por tener bien la documentación
no no no están citado tanto en el tema
de los precios pero obviamente a países
que se encuentran en más desigualdad así
que las afecta directamente de hecho en
el en el consejo de
europeo cuando se dijo que países tenían
que entrar para poder viajar solo por
ejemplo uruguay en latinoamérica ha sido
uno de los pocos que sí que se puede
viajar libremente
entonces no encontramos también con
marruecos que nada aquí entran a otras
partes entonces y todos los países
tienen también libraba el día a la hora
de decidir si tienen que cerrar
fronteras no tienen que cerrar fronteras
qué medidas tomar entonces la infracción
como tal por el momento es una
incertidumbre como hemos estado hablando
a lo largo del programa y bueno vamos a
ir viendo podría verlos a ustedes un
tema complejo pero al mismo tiempo
bastante interesante estamos poniendo ya
a punto final a esta primera plana no me
queda sino agradecer a mis invitados
álvaro zúñiga de la parís school of
economics miembro de laboratorio mundial
de las desigualdades a karen bujes
periodista e independiente ya distancia
a jean pierre duclós economista de la
universidad parís es más lavarle su
presencia en nuestros estudios a ustedes
les damos las gracias les invitamos a
otra cita aquí en primera plana